the Joe Rogan experience this is gonna
sound gay you know had the greatest back
of all time and all combat sports of all
combat sports hold on give me a weight
class Evander Holyfield
oh yes and his trash his truck just
started Oh bro start at the top of his
head to find my son come on so I'm most
impressive every combat supposed to
[ __ ] peaches hanging up the top find
out when he fought Tyson Evander
Holyfield when he fought Tyson just play
a clip of that you watch third or second
Olympia
he's so got George just that formal skin
and just he's up and he was one of the
first guys that figured out how to in
court prop look at that Jesus Christ
Jesus look at that back he was one of
the first guys that figured out how to
correctly implement weightlifting
training because a Mac ISIL style try
everyone thought to make you slower yeah
and he was one of the first guys that
really pulled it off and moved up a
weight class he was the cruiserweight
champion has a hard time making 195 is
like [ __ ] it we're going up and first
couple of fights I want to say he was
like you're like 205 maybe that's cool 9
yeah and he never got much higher to 11
to 12 yeah well it was the highest he
got I would say honestly like 2 to 118
yeah somewhere he's at the bite after
Tyson bit him that was the saddest [ __ ]
Holyfield overall had a better career
than Tyson oh for sure 226 so I probably
got up two times is that right now
that's not that's not as fighting late
by the way that's when they used to test
you with one of them Cracker Jacks rings
they would just wave it around you and
if it didn't show didn't change colors
everything everybody was on everything
there was no testing get the [ __ ] outta
here with your testing you think if Jon
Jones was just back then oh my god the
Chuck Liddell days yeah come on son
the Vanderley silver pride days yeah
yeah in the early days the way the best
guys would put it is you never knew who
was on anything because essentially it
was an intelligence test not a drug test
because they're only testing the day of
the fight most the guys have already
cycled off you keep all the benefits for
a long period of time and back then they
you know rudimentary tests they didn't
have the same kind of tests I have now
okay we're gonna [ __ ] traps on
holyfield Jesus son
it makes Tyson look smooth you know dude
dude he [ __ ] Tyson up in this fight I
mean I remember watching this with Kevin
James we're in my house and then Cena oh
dude it's beating the [ __ ] out of Tyson
how great at what time was that for they
stopped the fight right there I was at
the end of the round those around oh
dude give me some volume up in that
[ __ ] I want to hear this I remember
Kevin and I were jumping up and down on
the couch screaming I couldn't believe
it we couldn't believe it
everybody thought like Tyson was the
scariest guy ever and that the only guy
that ever beat him was Buster Douglas
and Evander Holyfield was not the same
size and there's and I was coming after
him for years just trying to make it
happen forever if you remember and
remember Evander had those crazy fights
with Riddick Bowe who was an enormous
guy monster boom look at this Holyfield
son to me it's no disrespect to Tyson
well I have Lennox Lewis and Evander
Holyfield I cut pound for pound overrun
yeah people forget ho leaf it was a
[ __ ] Olympian man correct
did he win a gold medal yes oh no he
don't bring it when I go bronze yeah
what did you got screwed in the Olympics
looked at a boom boom nobody got screwed
like Roy Jones jr. did nobody nobody
when he fought that Korean dude in the
Olympics that was one of the worst
robberies I've ever seen watching box
now that Irish kid who's fighting there
he goes
they just pushed him back out there I
mean Howerton is he
and Tyson charging forward do you know I
just did a potty laughter [ __ ] is it on
podcast called bite the mic oh [ __ ]
Oh boom goddamn dude look look at the
body on first team all bond
well Tyson just doesn't look physically
the same as he did like just coming out
of the pokey like he just does not have
the same build that's it stop the fight
[Applause]